american style sedans becoming
increasingly popular in europe today
we're checking out the lancia thema
which is in fact a second-generation
chrysler 300c hai yahan been here a few
years ago our test driver mattis was
driving around these parts in a Chrysler
300c wagon but feared has since bull
hump Chrysler and restructured the brand
a successor to the Chrysler 300c some
parts now also known as the Chrysler 300
is called the Lancia Thema in Europe
lancia thema Lancia hopes to win over
new customers with the team ER but its
success depends on the improvements made
some comfort features have been added
for the european version
was to get Matusz finds the car more
comfortable to drive in the Chrysler
300c the steering and gears are firmer
because they've been specially adapted
for the European market he also notes
that the brakes are more reliable than
they used to be laude Farley avz does
for yoga let's take a look at the FEMA
from the outside the bi-xenon headlights
come with a smart beam function so they
adjust from low to high beam
automatically the car has a wheelbase of
3.5 2 meters and 18-inch alloy wheels
come as standard
the trunk holds 462 litres before
folding down the rear seats overall the
car comes together harmoniously and both
the front and rear exuding american vibe
inside the lancia thema comes across as
tidy and functional with the upholstery
providing a luxurious feel the model we
tested had a 3.6 liter v6 gas engine
with an output of 210 kilowatts it
accelerates from nought to 100
kilometres an hour in 7.9 seconds it's
not the most energy efficient vehicle
however eating up nine point four liters
of fuel per 100 kilometers its top speed
is 240 kph
that's place licensed pay majus thinks
the cost effectiveness of the lancia
thema is truly phenomenal for a little
over 50000 euros he can get a model with
all the trimmings including a
leather-coated dash heated seats
ventilated seating up front or for
adaptive speed control line spot
detection I'm the sound system with an
8.4 inch touchscreen and I think
everything his heart could desire come
on fiat saw a touchscreen Alice fastest
out spaghett that's nice this almost
everything about the theme that comes
out top compared to its predecessor
except for one thing the navigation
system it had a large enough display but
sometimes it just don't react and fails
to display a map at times location pin
is 10 kilometres off the mark you
wouldn't recommend it to those who are
really reliant on Saturday then have you
got see one system I'm good reason is
that is the super hope leads the lancia
thema comes with a range of four engines
to gasoline and to diesel variant output
between hundred and forty hundred and
seventy-six and 210 kilowatts you also
have a choice between an eight speed or
five-speed automatic gearbox
as a been team up to is the theme ur an
American or Italian car while is matt is
the basic form is definitely American
except for a few Italian design elements
he also finds the interior more Italian
than American in the end he says it's a
car for individualists considering that
only a few hundred units were sold in
Germany over the last year and power and
that she looked a fun fact off the car
is a look at however and drives known as
comfortably competition theme is MIT der
Kolk events lancia thema it's available
in Germany from a starting price of
forty one thousand four hundred euros
though the model we tested costs fifty
thousand nine hundred